I am the one who knocks Walter White was
on a transformation and going through
this metamorphosis of a character and at
that particular point he was becoming
more emotional and more impulsive and
along with that his ego was increasing
and is hubris and he was not liking in
fact earlier in I think it's the same
episode where we're at dinner at the
schraders Hank Schrader thinks he's got
the guy he's got Heisenberg and it's
like it's interesting because if he
keeps his mouth shut that's great that's
better for business but there's
something that's driving him nuts that
he's going to give credit to this other
guy to Gail betteker and Walt can't take
that so his ego becomes part of his
Achilles heel and that's what this is
It's a final downfall here that he he
has to lay it on the line and tell her
just how powerful a man I am a guy opens
his door and gets shot and you think out
of me no